>> WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FARAWAY
PLACES AND THE WORLD, BUT EUROP
IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
EUROPE IS WHERE YOUR KIDS SPEND
THEIR YEAR ABROAD.
IT'S AN EASY FLIGHT FROM THE
EAST COAST OF THE UNITED STATES
TO PRETTY MUCH ANYWHERE IN THE
CONTINENT.
YOU KNOW THIS IF YOU BEEN ON
VACATION AREA.
THEY'VE GOT STARBUCKS AND TACO
BELL AND AIR-CONDITIONING AND
MODERN HOSPITALS FREIGHT IS NOT
ANOTHER WORLD.
GIVEN HOW CLOSELY RELATED THE
UNITED STATES IS TO EUROPE AND
HAS ALWAYS BEEN, YOU WOULD
IMAGINE OUR LEADERS WOULD NOTIC
WHEN EUROPE BEGAN TO FALL APART
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE SIGNS WERE
NOT SUBTLE AT ALL.
THEY WEREN'T.
THIS SUMMER GERMANS BEGIN
CLEARCUTTING ANCIENT FOREST TO
HEAT THERE HOMES.
IN POLAND, FAMILIES QUEUED UP
FOR ARROWS TO BICOL, LIKE THEY
DID 150 YEARS AGO.
IN THE UK, THE GOVERNMENT
PROJECTED THAT MORE THAN 10,000
BRITONS WILL FREEZE TO DEATH,
WILL DIE THIS WINTER FOR LACK O
HEATING FUEL.
IN ENGLAND.
THAT IS NOT SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN
IN A FIRST WORLD COUNTRY.
SO EUROPE IS MOVING BACKWARD AT
HIGH-SPEED.
THE WAR IN UKRAINE IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
A HUGE CAME FROM A SHEPHERD
THOSE IMPORTS HAVE BEEN BANNED.
WITH THE RESULT OF HIS
PUNISHMENT, THE RUSSIAN RUBLE I
NOW FAR STRONGER THAN IT WAS A
YEAR AGO.
THE EUROPEAN ECONOMY MEANWHILE
IS COLLAPSING.
EUROPEANS ARE MUCH POORER THAN
THEY WERE WHEN THE WAR IN
UKRAINE STARTED.
THAT BIDEN IN MINISTRATION IS
DOUBLING DOWN ON THE
SELF-DESTRUCTIVE MISTAKES THAT
ARE DESTROYING THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
WHITE HOUSE BAND NATURAL GAS AN
COAL.
IT WAS OUR NATURAL DUTY.
AT THE SAME TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION PRESSED
PRODUCTION HERE.
AND THEN, AS IF THAT WASN'T
ENOUGH, THE BIDEN MINISTRATIONS
OF THE TWO PETROLEUM RESERVE,
MEANING THIS COUNTRIES.
ALL OF IT IMPOVERISH AS THE
UNITED STATES.
ANYONE WHO HAS PAYING ATTENTION.
THIS WEEK, THE CONGRESSMAN
ANSWERED THAT QUESTION.
RUSSIA IS AN ORTHODOX CHRISTIAN
COUNTRY WITH TRADITIONAL SOCIAL
VALUES AND FOR THAT REASON, IT
MUST BE DESTROYED, NO MATTER
WHAT THE COST TO US.
THIS IS NOT A CONVENTIONAL WAR,
THIS IS A SHE HOG.
SHE SAID THAT OUTLAST LOUD, BUT
MANY AGREE WITH HIM.
MOST PARTIES, THEY WOULD LIKE T
SEE WORLD WAR II AND IMMEDIATELY
.
SO WHAT IS THIS GOING TO MEAN
FOR YOU?
WILL, THE DETAILS ARE STUNNING.
THANKS TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S RELIGIOUS WAR
AND THE UKRAINE, THIS COUNTRY I
ABOUT TO RUN OUT OF DIESEL FUEL.
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM THE
ENERGY INFORMATION BY THE MONDA
OF THANKSGIVING, 25 DAYS FROM
NOW, THERE WILL BE NO MORE
DIESEL.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN THEN?
EVERYTHING WILL STOP.
THAT MEANS TRUCKS AND TRAINS AN
BARGES ALL UNABLE TO MOVE.
FROM EQUIPMENT SHUTDOWN.
THERE WILL BE NO DELIVERIES AS
THERE WILL BE NO TRUCKS FOR
THERE WILL BE NO DIESEL
GENERATORS FREIGHT IN THAN
INEVITABLY OUR ECONOMY WILL
CRASH BECAUSE EVERYTHING RUNS O
DIESEL FUEL.
DIESEL IS NOT NEGOTIABLE
COMMODITY.
WHAT HAPPENS?
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THEM?
YESTERDAY, TECHIE HEINRICH
APPARENTLY ALONE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE PRESS CORPS IS THE
SPOKESMAN THAT VERY QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE PLAN HERE?
WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF DIESEL.
JOHN KIRBY STANDING AT THE
PODIUM REPRESENTING THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE LARGEST
ORGANIZATION IN HUMAN HISTORY
HAD NO ANSWER, BUT DON'T WORRY
HE'S HAD.
WE WILL BE EXPORTING PLENTY OF
ENERGY TO EUROPE TO HELP FIGHT
THAT PROGRESSIVE YOU FOR CRUSAD
IN UKRAINE.
WATCH.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING TO INCREAS
THE SUPPLY OF DIESEL.
WHEN YOU HAVE THEM ALREADY
RATIONING OIL, WHAT ARE WE DOIN
TO PREPARE FOR THE WINTER TO
RAMP UP SUPPLY OF DIESEL?
>> I WILL TAKE THE QUESTION ON
THE DIESEL BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
THE DATA ON THAT FREIGHT I WILL
TAKE THAT AND GET BACK TO YOU O
THAT.
BY A LARGE, THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE NOT ONLY ARE WE
READY FOR OF COURSE THE PRICES
ARE GOING DOWN AND WE THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
BUT THAT WE ARE ALSO DOING WHAT
WE CAN TO HELP ARE EUROPEAN
FRIENDS AND PARTNERS WHO ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE FACING A LONG
COLD WINTER.
WE HAVE DOUBLED OUR COMMITMENT,
THE COMMITMENT WE MADE IN MARCH
WE DOUBLED THAT COMMITMENT.
IN TERMS OF ACTUAL COMMITMENT,
AND GETTING NATURAL GAS OVER
THERE.
TO SEE IF WE CAN'T HELP ARE
EUROPEAN PARTNERS UPDATE THEIR
STORAGE AND SUPPLIES FOR ITS.
>> JUST AND SAY.
EVERYTHING IS IRONY.
THEY'VE BEEN TELLING YOU FOR
DECADES, SINCE AL GORE LEFT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THAT THE SINGLE
GREATEST THREAT TO THE WORLD WA
WARMING, AND BECAUSE OF THEIR
EFFORTS TO FIGHT FORMING, YOU
ARE IN DANGER OF FREEZING.
FREEZING KILLS A LOT OF PEOPLE,
YOU ARE IN DANGER OF DYING EVER
OTHER.
THEY WILL KILL PEOPLE AND THE
WEST THIS YEAR THANKS TO THE
EFFORTS TO FIGHT WARMING.
THE THINKING THE SECOND THING I
THE WHITE HOUSE SPOKESMAN'S
TOTALLY UNINTERESTED RESPONSE T
THE MOST BASIC QUESTION ANYONE
COULD ASK WHICH IS WHAT ARE WE
DOING ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE AR
RUNNING OUT OF DIESEL FUEL?
HE HAS NO IDEA IN IS NOT
EMBARRASSED THAT HE DOESN'T HAV
AN IDEA.
AT THIS POINT THERE MAY NOT BE
AN ANSWER BECAUSE THERE MAY NOT
BE AWAY TO AVOID A DISASTER.
IT IS LOW AND EVERY WESTERN
NATION THAT HIS ALIGNED ITSELF
WITH UKRAINE.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE RUNNING
OUT OF DIESEL FUEL.
AS NEW YORK MAGAZINE HAS
REPORTED LESS TIME THERE WAS
THIS LITTLE SUPPLY OF DIESEL
THERE WE'RE ABOUT 3.5 BILLION
FEWER PEOPLE ON THE PLANET THAT
PUTS IT INTO PERSPECTIVE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
RESPONDED AS YOU KNOW EARLIER
THIS YEAR WITH THE RISING GAS
PRICES AS THE MIDTERMS WERE
COMING TWO WEEKS BY TAPPING THE
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESULTS.
THE NORTHEAST HOME HEATING OIL
RESERVE 1 MILLION GALLONS OF
DIESEL IN CASE OF EMERGENCIES.
THE DEMAND IS SO HIGH ACROSS TH
BOARD THAT ACCORDING TO THE
WASHINGTON POST, EVEN IF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION USED EVERY
SINGLE BARREL IN THAT STOCKPILE
THAT STOCKPILE WOULD BE EMPTY I
LESS THAN SIX HOURS.
OF COURSE, IT'S NOT JUST DIESEL
THAT IS RUNNING OUT FOR JET FUE
IS UP ABOUT 23 PERCENT IN THE
LAST MONTH.
KEROSENE, WHICH WE DON'T LEAVE
IN NEW YORK CITY.
IS NOW CLOSE TO $7 A GALLON.
WHO HEATS WITH KEROSENE BY THE
WAY?
POOR PEOPLE EAT WITH KEROSENE'S
AND THEY'RE THE ONES THEY CAN'T
GET IT.
IN NEW ENGLAND PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT FREEZING TO DEATH
FRED.
>> WEST HARTFORD RESIDENT HAS
BEEN PAYING FOR OIL TO HEAT HER
HOME FOR MORE THAN 35 YEARS.
>> THIS IS NEW ENGLAND, IT GETS
COLD HERE.
>> SHE IS A WIDOW LIVING ON
FIXED INCOME, SHE SAYS BEFORE
HER HUSBAND PASSED AWAY, THEY
SHARED THE BILLS, NOW SHE IS
HAVING TO MAKE SACRIFICES.
>> HOW ARE YOU PREPARING AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT CAN
YOU SACRIFICE AT THIS POINT?
>> FOOD.
I GO TO THE GROCERY STORE AND
I'M VERY FRUGAL ABOUT WHAT I BUY
.
>> SHE TELLS ME AT $6 A GALLON,
BUYING OIL HAS BECOME A HUGE
BURDEN.
THE AVERAGE HOME USES 800
GALLONS OF OIL PER YEAR,
THAT'S ALMOST $5,000 AT THE
CURRENT RATE.
>> THEY SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING
IN THIS COUNTRY COME TO THE
UNITED STATES HAS SOME OF THE
DEEPEST BY SOME MEASURES THE
DEEPEST ENERGY RESERVES ON THE
PLANET.
IT IS OUR MAIN STRENGTH FOR A
CHEAP ENERGY IS THE REASON THIS
IS A RICH COUNTRY.
THAT IS THE REASON.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE EXCEPTIONAL
BECAUSE WE HAVE CHEAP ENERGY.
THIS COUNTRY'S ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE A FEW YEARS AGO,
NOW IF YOU WANT TO FIX THE
ECONOMY, HE WOULD MAKE THIS KIN
ENERGY ENERGY INDEPENDENT ONCE
AGAIN.
YOU WOULD BRING BACK CHEAP
ENERGY.
THAT IS THE ONLY THING THAT WIL
FIX THE ECONOMY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR
WHATEVER REASON HAS DONE THE
OPPOSITE.
THEY KNOW THAT THAT IS RUNNING
OUT, THE WHITE HOUSE IS BEGGING
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS FOR HELP.
IN THE MOST HUMILIATING POSSIBL
WAY, THE NEW YORK TIMES REPORTE
THIS WEEK, THAT TOP AIDES STRUC
A SECRET DEAL TO PRODUCE OIL
PRODUCTION UNTIL THE END OF THE
YEAR, BUT THE SAUDI ROYAL FAMIL
DECIDED NOT TO GO ALONG WITH IT.
THERE DOING THE OPPOSITE PER TH
OIL MINISTER TOLD US TO BRACE
FOR ENERGY SHORTAGES.
>> IT IS MY PROFOUND DUTY TO
MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE WORLD, THA
USING EMERGENCY STOCK MAY BECOM
PAINFUL IN THE MONTHS TO COME.
>> AND ENERGY SHORTAGE IS NOT A
DEBATE OVER WHETHER SOME DUDE
SHOULD BE ON THE SWIM TEAM, THI
IS ADULT STUFF, COUNTRIES RISE
AND FALL ON THE BASIS OF WHAT
ENERGY COSTS.
WHEN THERE IS A REAL ENERGY
SHORTAGE, THINGS FALL APART AND
PEOPLE DIE, ECONOMIES COLLAPSE.
SYSTEMIC POVERTY SETS IN.
THIS IS A REAL THING.
THE PROBLEM IS, THE PEOPLE
RUNNING THE GOVERNMENT OUR
CHILDREN.
THEY NOT ONLY CAN'T ADMIT WHAT
THEY'VE DONE WRONG, THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT.
YOUR IS THAT GLASS CEILING
SHATTERING SPOKESPERSON AT THE
WHITE HOUSE ADDRESSING THE
QUESTION IS TODAY.
>> I WANT.
>> YOU'RE THOUGHTS ON THIS NEW
YORK TIMES REPORT THAT U.S.
OFFICIALS THAT THEY HAD TO DEAL
WITH THE SAUDIS BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT WENT TO SAUDI ARABIA
FOR HIS MEETING WITH THE CROWN
PRINCE FREIGHT THEY HAVE THOUGH
THEY A DEAL, BUT THE SAUDI'S
BACKED OUT OF THAT DEAL.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> WE HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOU
HOW WE BELIEVE PARTS OF THAT
REPORT WAS MISCHARACTERIZED AND
THERE HAS BEEN SOME CHANGES THA
HAVE BEEN MADE TO THAT REPORTS.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN CLEAR THAT OUR
TRIP, THE PRESIDENT'S TRIP TO
THE MIDDLE EAST WAS NOT ABOUT
OIL.
>> WITH THE SAUDI'S AND THE
BACKED AWAY FROM HER AT.
>> AGAIN, THE TRIP WAS NOT ABOU
OIL.
>> THIS IS EMBARRASSING PERIGEE
CAN'T EVEN CONJUGATE THE VERB
CORRECTLY.
IT'S A SPOKESPERSON.
IT'S A JOKE.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT OIL IS AN
SHE'S LYING.
THEY ARE ALL LIKE THAT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT CAPABLE OF
RUNNING A COUNTRY THIS BIG AND
THIS COMPLEX AND THAT IS WHY
IT'S FALLING APART.
JOE BIDEN IS BLAMING GAS
STATIONS FOR GAS PRICES BRIDGE
HOW IS KAMALA HARRIS RESPONDING
THIS?
SHE'S TELLING YOU THAT DIESEL I
BRAD PITT.
>> I HAVE A FONDNESS FOR
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES.
ON A DAILY BASIS, 25 MILLION
CHILDREN IN OUR COUNTRY EVERY
DAY GO TO SCHOOL.
ON THOSE DIESEL FUELED SCHOOL
BUSES.
HUNDREDS, THOUSANDS OF SCHOOL
BUS DRIVERS ARE DRIVING THOSE
BUSES.
WHICH ARE THEN, THESE PEOPLE,
THESE CHILDREN, THESE ADULTS
AREN'T HANDLING WHAT IS TOXIC
AIR.
>> SO THE LADY WHO NEVER HAD
CHILDREN IS LECTURING YOU ABOUT
CHILDREN.
THE PERSON WHO HAS NEVER HAD A
REAL JOB IS LECTURING YOU ABOUT
ENERGY POLICY.
SHE'S TELLING YOU OUT DIESEL
FUMES AND THE EFFECT ON YOU.
THE TRUTH IS THESE PEOPLE ARE
BUMPING RIGHT SMACK UP AGAINST
REALITY.
HERE IS THE REALITY.
YOU HAVE 25 DAYS TO EVE AVERT
ECONOMIC.
THAT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PROSECUTING A JIHAD IN UKRAINE.
EVERYTHI